[Musik]
möchte so ein bisschen Liebe in die
Ampel wiederbringen weil das ist ja doch
gerade irgendwie eine zermirbende Zeit
ne ja so ganz einfach ist es nicht so
ein bisschen ja aber Krisen kommen in
jeder Ehe vor das kenne ich in fast 20
Jahren jetzt verheiratet sein von daher
läuft es auch privat schlecht ne es
läuft super es gibt immer mal wieder
Krisen manchmal ist man gerade mit den
Leuten die man liebt besonders kritisch
und das zeigt sich eben auch in der
Koalition lieben sie die Grünen aber
sehr oder das richtig heiße wenn das der
Maßstab ist dann ist das eine toxische
on and off Beziehung in der wir uns
total wohlfühlen ja was ist denn ihr
lieblingstoxischer Partner in der
Koalition wir haben gar keine toxische
Partnerschaft wir machen
Gesprächstherapie sie sollen ja als
Zeichen der Liebe jemand von den Grünen
schenken oder von der jemand hier haben
wir jemanden von den Grünen hier dem ich
die schenken könnte ja da ist doch wo
doch Bruno kann ich dir eine Rose
schenken Bruno ich wollte dir schon
immer diese Rose schenken weil ich finde
ganz so schlimm ist das mit der
Ampelkoalition gar nicht vielleicht
können wir doch ein bisschen weiter
machen auf jeden Fall auf persönlicher
Ebene läuft das wunderbar bei uns auf
persönlicher auf politischer Ebene halt
nicht auch da sind die Gemeinsamkeiten
gar nicht so gering wie viele denken
würden Sie sagen Schnittblumen sind ein
gutes Symbol für die Koalition weil sie
sind tot aber ein paar Tage machen sie
es noch na D würde ich das nicht sagen
aber schöne rote Hose ich glaub die
schenke ich vstag Zimmermann mus einehen
die freunden sich bestimmt ja kann sich
oben auf ein gepanzertes Fahrzeug stcken
also das heißt da ist schon in der Ampel
es gibt schon so Moment wo man sagt da
da ist doch liebe da und da ist noch so
ein Funkeln und da ist auch so ein
bisschen von dieser ersten Verliebtheit
da ja wir schreiben auch gern sozusagen
Briefe an den Kanzler und was steht da
drin dass er endlich sein Arsch bewegen
soll und das tun soll was notwendig
[Musik]
ist ich würde ihnen abschließend gerne
noch Massageöl mitgeben wen könnten Sie
sich vorstellen gleich hier im Saal mal
schön zu durchzumassieren paar Blockaden
zu lösen mitten im Saal ja das ist ein
Zeichen nach draußen dass da Liebe ist
wie würden Sie den kobikiieren eher so
so sanft oder so dass es weh tut dass
sie sie den so richtig
durchknetten sind ja die wo es wirklich
man draußen so Schreie hört so würden
sie den K gern durchmassieren sch hört
so wie beim Zahnarzt manche sagen wir
haben 170 Gesetze gemacht aber das hört
sich natürlich unerotisch an oder weil
man nicht weiß was drin ist ich kann mir
nichts ungeileres vorstellen als 170
Gesetze ja ja ja das ist aber ein
erweiterter erotikbegriff können Sie
denn einmal
vielleicht drei Eigenschaften nennen die
sie an der FDP besonders
lieben die erste Eigenschaft ist
stakzimmermann die zweite Eigenschaft
des stragzimmermann und die dritte
Eigenschaft des stagzimmermann oh da
geht was oder selbstverständlich ich
habe her ein Hofreiter eben gefragt
nennen Sie drei Dinge an der FDP die sie
lieben wissen Sie was er gesagt hat frau
schck Zimmermann Frau Sch Zimmermann
Frau Zimmermann Tony Tony so jetzt ist
doch noch was geworden mit der Hose ganz
genau aber das ist doch schön oder ist
ein Traum der Tag ist gerettet ich bin
ihnen so dankbar wir haben uns alle lieb
piep piep
piep sie müssen die wirklich nehmen sie
müssen die nehmen verstehen sie den
nicht aberiert aber es geht doch auch
über die über die Sendung hinaus es geht
doch nicht nur immer um Fernsehen es
geht darum dass das ein wichtiges Symbol
ist hier komme ich nicht durch ich leg
die Rose hier hin neh holen Sie sie
gleich wieder ab ach Mann zurück ins
Studio es war doch so knapp Mensch
[Musik]
Kinder so
Aufnahme h dies ist die automatische
endcard von Oliver Welke und der heute
show leider ist das Video schon vorbei
ihr könnt den Kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres Video
anschauen vielen Dank so müsste jetzt
für immer reichen